on retrouve justement alexandre kateb
économiste et fondateur du site de
multipolarité report bonjour tout
d'abord quelle est l'efficacité des
sanctions prises contre la russie par
les européens les américains
l'efficacité des sanctions en fait se
mesure à plusieurs niveaux c'est à dire
que certes les sanctions auront un
impact sur les personnalités et sur les
organisations qui sont concernées elles
vont le rendre la vie plus difficile
mais pour autant elle ne consiste je ne
constitue pas je dirais un vecteur
suffisamment puissant pour
couper l'herbe sous le pied entre
guillemets à l'état russe et notamment
j'en veux pour preuve pour preuve que le
secteur de l'énergie n'est pas vraiment
sanctionnés certes le processus de
certification dindar street 2 a été
suspendu dès ce gazoduc n'a jamais été
en opération contrairement à north
stream aaa et continue lui de
fonctionner et toutes les tous les
approvisionnements de gaz à destination
de l'europe continue de sa cheminée et
c'est là c'est la même chose pour les
approvisionnements de pétrole
donc oui en effet les sanctions vont
compliquer la vie
pour l'économie russe mais il faut se
rappeler que les premières sanctions ont
été imposées déjà en 2014 et donc il ya
une certaine résilience est une forme de
cohabitation et de on va dire de
transformation d'adaptation de
l'économie russe et du poids russell ces
sanctions qui font que leur alors un
pacte en fait leur efficacité diminue au
fil du temps et aujourd'hui il existe
des alternatifs la sanction la sanction
suprême c'est des conclusions de la
russie du système swift swift le système
de transactions financières pourquoi y
at-il eu des réticences je ne sais pas
où yat il des réticences de l'allemagne
y at-il eu des réticences de l'italie
je pense personnellement que la russie
ne sera jamais exclu du système swift
sont vraiment si
la poutine décidé d'attaquer les pays
baltes ou quelque chose comme ça mais en
réalité à ce stade il faut il faut
savoir que sanctionner la russie l'a
privé de l'accès au système swift aurait
des conséquences immédiates sur un
certain nombre d'institutions
financières occidentales
américaines et européennes notamment et
que
les effets en cascade risquerait de
déstabiliser l'ensemble du système
financier mondial et ça c'est quelque
chose qui a été dit par le président du
comité de stabilité financière mondiale
lui même donc on voit bien que en fait
cette menace n'est pas vraiment prise au
sérieuse y compris par les autorités
russes elle même le président russe
vladimir poutine lui va riposter quelle
peut être la riposte
la riposte bon être assez classique à
c'est à dire qu'il va lui aussi
sanctionné un certain nombre de
personnalités ou d'organisations
européennes
mais là on est plus dans le titre forte
at c'est à dire dans quelque chose qui
qui qui est au niveau de la réaction
diplomatique si on veut plus et
symbolique plus que d'une volonté réelle
de de nuire à l'économie européenne
parce que au final le gaz lui ne sera
jamais suspendu la russie elle allant
des ponts pour ses rentrées financières
et leurs enfants des cours pour son
approvisionnement pour énergétique tout
simplement et c'est je crois le secteur
le plus important tout le reste
finalement et je ne dirais pas que c'est
négligeable année c'est secondaire s'il
ya des cyber attaques qui sont redoutées
jusqu'où peut aller la russie
cyberattaques c'est que c'est une
réalité
dans le monde dans lequel on vit qui ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui et et qui en fait
a été bien illustré quand les des
hackers russes ont se sont attaqués à
des processus électoraux par exemple aux
états unis ou ailleurs wade d
organisation
qui avaient des positions qu'ils
estimaient antirusse mai mais ça va
continuer ça va probablement
s'intensifier dans les années à venir
mais au même titre que dans les pays
occidentaux les agences officielles elle
même finalement recrue des hackers pour
attaquer les installations et les
intérêts des puissances qui ils jugent
hostile que ce soit la russie ou la
chine et ça c'est bien connu au sein des
milieux de renseignement et même au delà
alors vous ne le disais pour revenir sur
l'énergie c'est à double tranchant il ya
une interdépendance à ce qu'il faut
s'attendre concrètement en europe à des
pénuries en termes de gaz et puis
quelles peuvent être les conséquences
sur les prix
je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de pénurie
vraiment
de manière durable il peut y avoir
quelques perturbations dans
l'approvisionnement
en gaz de certains pays notamment à
travers le gazoduc
donc une douche bas qui passe par
l'ukraine mais en raison d'ajustements
des hostilités et de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
mais pour le reste en fait ça ne devrait
pas avoir tellement d'un paquet russes
n'ont pas intérêt à ce qu'il y ait de
description à ce niveau là y compris une
destruction qui serait causée de leur
fait qu'ils sont très attentifs à cela
et des autres des consignes en probables
ont été données à toutes les unités
opérationnelles sur le terrain et
du côté européen aussi on anticipe à
queue qu'il y ait ce genre de
d'éventualités je pense que par exemple
la menace concernant swift c'est une
sorte de d'armes de destruction massive
économique qui est brandi au cas où la
russie aurait en tête de couper le gaz
par exemple mais aucune des deux parties
n'a finalement intérêts merci beaucoup
alexandre kateb d'avoir été avec nous
sur france 24 merci à vous